now I in most cases i'll probably have
put more working than you have but you
guys know how i feel about that i'm
trying to make it clear to you so you
can look at this and you don't really
need me at all and secondly i'm trying
to make sure that if i get something
wrong I have a path back through so i
can say well which of my numbers is
wrong like why have i got something
which seems ridiculous okay so the first
thing i said is you've got this sub call
rate and they're charging in i hope you
were i hope you are underlining as you
went charging in 60 second intervals
right so the first thing I'm actually
written down is to take that seven
minutes and eight seconds it doesn't
matter that it's eight seconds it could
be any number of seconds more than zero
okay and as soon as you've gone into
seven minutes or something that means
you've got eight chunks of time okay you
can see if it were for example 30 second
intervals 30 second intervals how would
the next line change what would i have
written instead if there were 30 second
chance yeah so if i did seven minutes
right that would be exactly 14 intervals
because it's the tough right but as soon
as you go into the next one but eight
seconds now you're in the fifteenth
interval right so then i would just say
15 instead okay so i've noted that
there's going to be eight the reason why
i said on this next line number one when
you the marker look at my working this
number here doesn't just appear from
nowhere right and secondly for me when
i'm checking back after like okay your
HSC exam which they've just done like a
whisker two and a half hours long if
this was the first question i did two
and a half hours later i don't remember
that i did this question physically
don't remember so looking back am i
working and I'm like there's an eight
there why is there an eight there so
this slide here helps me remember okay
this is why it's there is this where i
got it wrong or is it something else in
the question six dollars 68 what do you
think yep happy wonderful so give that a
tick and let's move on the graph below
shows the call charges from a mobile
phone what kind of graph is call again
starts with an S a step graph because it
looks like set of steps what's the
connection face so this is actually kind
of two questions balled into one which
was a bit
you have a look at how I've worked
through this right in order to work out
the connection fee that's something
which happens over here right like as in
from the get-go you got charged this but
you can't simply say if this was a
multiple choice question a comment
distractor is what what is this distance
here what cost is that it looks like a
dollar 25 to me because each of the
marks the horizontal lines is 25 cents
and there are five of them so a dollar
25 is a common incorrect answer because
that a dollar 25 includes more than just
the connection fee what else isn't
include very good it includes the first
time interval the first minute of charge
so that's why you can see up here I
wanted to work out what do each of these
arrows represent this is these ones it
in PR this is going from one minute to
to to to this to 32 minutes 24 this is
the rate per minute I've even written
that down here for myself right each bit
is separated by 75 cents so this is the
rate per minute yeah question
okay so did you get the answer right no
you're right yeah sure okay so the
question is why do I need to find out
the rate per minute if the question is
not asking you what the rate per minute
is and the answer is in here this amount
that I was highlighting before it has
the connection fee and it has the rate
per minute so i can't get just the
connection for you by itself until I
find out what the right pivot is and
then I can separate that up okay so
that's why you can see what my working
looks like sorry let me change the color
again my working pulls out the fact that
I've got this Rick per minute which I
don't want so that's why I get
subtracted do you see that so there's
the amount that you guys read off the
graph from the beginning but you take
away the rate per minute which leaves
you in the connection fee does that make
sense do you see how you're in it okay
so you can see again careful reading of
grams I just want fairly straightforward
I think so speaks to the car you can see
as well like i mentioned this is more
working that you require if you had gone
straight to this solution I'd be pretty
happy with that they did get the tick
however for myself I've done this
conversion first because what do you
think if you are writing this is like a
multiple choice question what do you
think would be a common wrong answer to
right at you seven point 05 is is the
most common one because people like our
in scientific notation Modell what do I
have to do with that and so they say ah
I need these first digits and then they
forget actually this to pass this
question here's the rowdy and that's a
whole separate think so this really
would be too much so I've done that I've
rounded it then I can bet okay should we
have a look over here are the dreaded
conversions of different okay so if
you've got confused here don't feel bad
that's why we're doing this right so the
first thing I'm done is just this
conversion okay
now please look carefully please look
carefully I remember we were quite
confused as we went through this so let
me try and go through this slowly and
help you understand how I'm from line to
line okay when I see megabytes the first
thing I do is I say that every megabyte
by definition and megabyte is 1024
kilobytes right so five point nine five
point nine megabytes is five point nine
of those but then following along with
that every kilo bet by definition is
1024 bytes so I'm replacing one kilobyte
with a thousand and twenty four bytes
then I replace every buy it with a bits
and the last thing I do to trickiest bit
for most of us is I've been multiplying
all the way through I've been
multiplying and getting bigger and
bigger numbers because each of these
units is smaller than the previous one
right when you go from big units to
small units because they're so tiny you
need lots and lots and lots of them so
that's why this number here is massive
okay but the difference is when I do the
last step I'm not going to a smaller
unit anymore am I I'm going to a bigger
unit so there are less of them which is
why i have divided but why do you do it
doesn't okay great question why a
thousand and not a thousand 24 yeah do
they send a killer bit okay so when you
think about going from here to here
right when you're in bytes here the
mines megabytes etc you can see you're
in x 1024 1 million 14,500 seven sixes
because bites are these funny like not
decimal sizes and I did devote like
under flipping 10 minutes to explain why
that is if you're like okay I don't
worry about because you don't need to
know the why what you need to do is
remember which one is which bites are in
eight and awkward numbers like these
1024 but bits are individual you could
trade ten one hundred or a thousand of
them so that's why this is here and i
want to point out again that is not on
the reference
it's not on the reference sheet all
these other conversions they are but you
need to remember that when you're going
from bits in between those the magazine
kilos I just did their back to decimal
just like everything else and it is
confusing I agree so what you get down
to the end I've finally gotten to a
point where actually evaluate the number
if you just had 49,000 492 I'd be okay
with that this question is not about
rounding but I just decide to keep them
all because why not okay now when you're
working out how long it takes to
download that you can again see my
working now I've chosen to do this in
two steps I chosen to work out the speed
first and then go to time rather than
just doing time all together and try to
do all of that sorry all of the
conversions in here okay you don't have
to do it that way you can see when i
went from speed i converted from
megabits per second to kilo bits per
second I didn't go to for example I
didn't go to bits per second because
someone give me a suggestion as to why I
went and stopped it that unit yeah
fantastic well done early on you've got
that the par-tay told you're in these
units you might as well convert to those
I mean you can't convert to business
just extra steps for you ok so we've
seen this before when you got a
multi-part question pay attention to hot
the thing as a whole once you get
speeding kilobits per second then you
just have to divide like to think of
this a bit like um time we often say is
distance over speed like if you were
travelling at some number of kilometers
per hour okay and this is just like it's
a distance I have to cover it just
happens to be in the language of data
okay so distance over speed and that
gives you you can also see your
community center cancel and you want to
end up with seconds okay you can
obviously check you know if the other
common mistake you would do is dividing
the other way around and if you have a
go at that this is all in seconds right
so 1200 / about 50,000 is going to be
like 0.2 of a second which is very fast
so you think huh okay
maybe something's gone wrong so you can
do a sense check on that alright any
questions on number four before we move
to the last one okay I'll move down and
then I'll come back to this for anyone
who wants to join through it ok because
question fire would be really quick I
promise so here's the radar chart now
you can see what I chose to do on here
hey grab a seat um what I chose to do on
here was before I answered any questions
I just I read off the numbers now to be
fair like okay maybe you thought that
was closer to 2.5 and 2.4 with questions
like this when we're expecting you to
read you will either get one or two
things you'll get more detail on the you
know the lines like this detail such
that we expect you to be able to do it
and we put the numbers the Lions exactly
on the grid okay or alternatively if you
see something like this there will be a
threshold okay so you should be able to
see we're halfway between two things is
and you should be able to judge where
it's a bubble below but they'll accept a
range of artists so don't freak out if
your numbers slightly disagree with mine
I've read them all off I've done the
best I've can going around and then I've
looked at the questions you were my
answers I read off March and May looked
like they were the closest to me because
based on my reading I thought they were
both about 2.6 here okay you can see
September and January are closed
contenders but I think March and May
looked closer together okay yeah so like
I said january-september II uh I don't
know it yeah I in this question I
probably I probably would not pay
january-september September other
because i think it's reasonably clear
that january is is less than half way
between two and three
yeah they definitely will consider tray
I'll show you a better eat up was the
next one so when you have a look at the
next question right soon when you look
at the next question there's going to be
more flexibility here because we know
about limits of reading right limits
really something we study back in MN 1
right so we don't we know you can't do
this perfectly so if you read this up or
down point 1 and you read this up or
down point 1 then your answer could be
1.6 or 1.8 and those would all be a cell
because like oh yeah if you if you went
up and down then yes that's that's
positive what you'll find is that this
there's not a hard and fast rule on that
if you're unsure just get a roll around
like if we print it with enough detail
that you can get this reasonably
accurate yeah